it is a sort of a a Mount Everest
question that you just wanted to solve
because it states every is a major
breakthrough on a subject that has
bedeviled mathematicians since this new
results by Jung Hyung which says that
there are actually infinite many pairs
of primes which is separated by no more
than about 70 million new started
spreading through Twitter that the
mathematician had proved that prime gaps
were bounded so when I saw that I was
immediately interested and I started
calling up some mathematicians the thing
is this real you know who is this person
never heard of him absolutely never
heard of him and when I heard a rumor
about that that was possible this was
done and roughly what techniques were
used I said there's no way somebody I've
never heard of has done this I mean
really unusual to have someone like you
know sort of outside the math world or
just on the fringe of it just come up
with this kind of result and be
basically seems pretty normal I really
believe the mathematics should be very
pure I love math no one taught me but
myself I like to read to learn and to
think although we say the mathematics
city should be logical of course it is
logical but at the very beginning you
are thinking you are feeling this seems
very unclear then you try to make it a
clearer and clearer again that could be
say intuition situations sometimes the
heart that was described by words